He estado en el MIT durante 44 años. Asistí a TED I.
Sólo hay otra persona aquí, creo, que también asistió.
En todas las otras TED (asistí a todas, bajo el reinado de Ricky)
hablé de las actividades del Media Lab,
que hoy cuenta con casi 500 personas.
Si leen la prensa, la semana pasada decía que renuncié a Media Lab.
No lo hice; renuncié a la presidencia...
era un título algo ridículo, pero alguien más lo asumió,
y una de las cosas que uno puede hacer como profesor,
es seguir siendo profesor.
Ahora, y por el resto de mi vida, me dedicaré a Una Laptop Por Niño,
de todas formas, es algo que he estado haciendo durante un año y medio.
Así que les voy a contar sobre esto,
voy a usar mis 18 minutos para contarles por qué,
cómo y qué estoy haciendo.
Y en cierto momento haré circular, inclusive,
lo que podría ser la laptop de los 100 dólares.
Bueno, Chris me pidió que cuente los grandes retos,
así que comenzaré con los tres que me llevaron a hacer esto.
Y el primero es bastante obvio.
Es curioso, cuando uno conoce a un jefe de Estado y pregunta:
"¿Cuál es su recurso natural más valioso?"
Los niños no son lo primero que mencionan,
y al mencionar a los niños, rápidamente están de acuerdo.
Así que este punto no es tan difícil.
Todos concuerdan que cualquiera sea la solución a los grandes problemas,
se incluye la educación; a veces es sólo la educación
pero siempre hay un componente educativo.
Definitivamente es parte de la solución.
El tercer elemento es un poco menos obvio.
Y es que todos en esta sala aprendimos a caminar y hablar
no porque nos hayan enseñado cómo caminar o hablar,
sino interactuando con el mundo,
obteniendo ciertos resultados a partir de saber pedir algo
o de pararse y alcanzarlo.
Cerca de los seis años nos dicen que ya no aprendamos así,
y desde entonces todo aprendizaje se da mediante la enseñanza,
sea esta en forma presencial, como ahora, o mediante un libro, etc.
Pero era a través de la enseñanza.
Y uno de los aportes de la computación a la enseñanza
es que ahora brinda una forma de aprender
similar a la de caminar y hablar,
en el sentido que tiene mucho de autodidacta.
Con esos principios...
algunos ya conocen a Seymour Papert,
esto es en 1982, cuando trabajábamos en Senegal.
Algunos piensan que la laptop de 100 dólares surgió hace un año,
o dos años, o que llegó por inspiración divina.
Esto en realidad se remonta a los '60s.
Aquí estamos en los '80s.
Steve Jobs nos donó algunas laptops; estábamos en Senegal.
Esto no prosperó pero al menos llevó computadoras a países en desarrollo,
y aprendimos rápidamente que estos niños...
si bien el inglés no era su idioma,
y el alfabeto latino apenas les era familiar,
se sentían como peces en el agua;
podían tocar los teclados como pianos.
Hace poco me involucré personalmente.
Y estas son dos anécdotas: una en Camboya,
en una aldea sin electricidad, ni agua, ni televisión, ni teléfono,
pero ahora tiene banda ancha.
La primera palabra en inglés de estos niños es "Google",
y sólo conocen Skype. No conocen la telefonía.
Bien, sólo usan Skype.
Y por las noches en sus casas tienen banda ancha
en una choza sin electricidad.
A los padres les encanta, porque cuando encienden la laptop,
es la fuente de luz más brillante de la casa.
En cuanto a metáforas y realidades que se mezclan...
esta es la escuela.
Al mismo tiempo, Seymur Papert logró que el gobernador de Maine
legislara sobre Una Laptop Por Niño en 2002.
En ese momento 80% de los profesores se mostraban...
digamos, reticentes.
Realmente estaban completamente en contra.
Preferían que ese dinero se usara
en salarios, más escuelas, etc.
Ahora, tres años y medio después, adivinen.
Se informan cinco cosas.
Disminución de ausentismo a casi cero; las reuniones de padres...
a las que nadie asistía y ahora todos asisten
Disminución de la indisciplina, aumento de la participación estudiantil.
Los maestros ahora dicen que enseñar es divertido;
los niños están entusiasmados. Tienen laptops.
Y el quinto punto, el que más me interesa,
es que los servidores tienen que apagarse a cierta hora de la noche
porque los profesores reciben demasiados correos
de los niños solicitándoles ayuda.
Así, cuando vemos esas cosas, no es necesario hacer más pruebas.
Se acabaron los proyectos pilotos, donde se decía:
"Bueno, probaremos tres o cuatro mil en nuestro país y veremos qué pasa".
Olvídenlo. Vaya al final de la cola, que otro lo hará
y cuando vean que esto funciona, pueden sumarse también.
Y esto es lo que estamos haciendo.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Una Laptop por Niño se constituyó hace un año y medio.
Es una organización sin fines de lucro que recaudó unos 20 millones de dólares
para la ingeniería previa y la construcción posterior.
La escala es en verdad importante.
No porque se puedan comprar componentes a precios bajos...
sino porque se puede ir al fabricante...
(no lo voy a mencionar)
queríamos una pantalla pequeña, no requería perfecta uniformidad de color,
podía faltarle uno o dos píxeles, o no ser tan brillante.
Y este fabricante en particular dijo:
"Bien, no nos interesa. Nos interesa la sala de estar,
la perfecta uniformidad de color,
Nos interesan pantallas grandes, pantallas brillantes.
Ustedes no son parte de nuestro plan estratégico".
Y yo dije: "Bueno, es una lástima,
porque necesitamos 100 millones por año".
Y dijeron: "Bueno, quizá podamos formar parte de su plan estratégico".
Por eso es que importa la escala.
Y por eso no lo lanzaremos sin contar con 5 a 10 millones de unidades iniciales.
La idea es lanzarlo con una escala suficiente
que ayude a bajar el precio,
por eso dije de 7 a 10 millones.
Y lo estamos haciendo sin equipo de marketing y ventas.
Quiero decir, yo soy el equipo de ventas y marketing.
Lo haremos yendo a siete países grandes para acordar el lanzamiento,
y los demás nos seguirán.
Tenemos socios; es fácil adivinar que Google será uno de ellos,
los demás están en suspenso.
Esto ha recibido mucha cobertura de prensa.
Es la llamada Máquina Verde que presentamos con Kofi Annan
en noviembre, en la Cumbre Mundial de Túnez.
La gente ve esto y dice: ah, es un proyecto de laptops.
Bueno, no, no lo es. Es un proyecto educativo.
Y lo gracioso es que (me he concentrado en esto)
le digo a la gente que yo solía ser un foco pero ahora soy un láser.
Sólo quiero que esto sea realidad
y resulta que no es tan difícil.
Porque los costos de las laptops son los siguientes:
el 50%, o mejor el 60%,
el 60% del costo de una laptop va a ventas, marketing, distribución y utilidades.
No tenemos nada de eso aquí, ¿bien?
Nada de eso entra en nuestro costo.
Porque vendemos al costo y los gobiernos las distribuyen.
Se distribuyen a través del sistema educativo como un libro.
Así que esa parte del costo desaparece, y nos quedamos con la pantalla y el resto.
La pantalla de una laptop cuesta, aproximadamente,
10 dólares por pulgada diagonal.
Y eso puede bajar a 8, puede bajar a 7,
pero no va a bajar a 2, o 1.5,
a menos que actuemos ingeniosamente.
El resto (esa cajita marrón) es fascinante,
porque el resto de la laptop está dedicada a sí misma.
Es como una persona obesa que usa la mayor parte
de su energía en mover su obesidad, ¿bien?
Y hoy vemos una situación increíble.
Uso laptops desde que salieron.
Hoy mi laptop es más lenta, menos confiable y placentera que antes.
Y este año es peor.
Hoy la gente aplaude, a veces de pie, y digo:
"¿Qué les pasa? ¿Por qué quedamos ahí sentados?"
Alguien, que no mencionaré, llamó a nuestra laptop un dispositivo.
Y dije: Dios, nuestra laptop va a ir rapidísimo.
Cuando la abran: ¡bingo! Estará encendida, lista para usar.
Va a ser como en 1985, cuando uno compraba una Apple Macintosh 512.
Funcionaba muy bien.
Hemos ido empeorando continuamente.
La gente siempre pregunta qué es.
Es eso.
Las dos cosas más notables: será una red de malla,
cuando los niños abran sus laptops conformarán una red,
sólo se necesita uno o dos puntos de distribución.
Puede darse acceso a un par de miles de niños con 2Mb.
Se brinda acceso a una aldea,
y luego las aldeas pueden comunicarse,
puede hacerse bastante bien.
La pantalla bimodo: la idea es tener una pantalla que funcione al aire libre
¿no es genial usar el celular al aire libre?
Bueno, la pantalla no se puede ver.
Una de las causas es la iluminación de fondo
de los celulares.
Ahora estamos haciendo iluminación de frente y de fondo.
Ya sea manualmente o por software, se verá.
Cuando es de fondo, es a color...
y de frente es en blanco y negro, a tres veces la resolución.
¿Está todo resuelto? No.
Por eso mucha de nuestra gente ahora casi vive en Taiwan.
En 30 días sabremos si funcionó.
Probablemente lo más importante
es que los niños pueden hacer el mantenimiento.
y esto, de nuevo, es algo que la gente no cree,
pero pienso que es verdad.
Esa es la máquina que mostramos en Túnez
y esta es la dirección en la que vamos.
Es algo que pensábamos imposible.
Iré pasando esto.
No es un diseño, ¿bien?
Es como un dispositivo mecánico para jugar.
Claramente, es un modelo.
El original está en MIT.
Lo voy a pasar a este guapo caballero.
Luego decidan si va a la izquierda o...
...el simulcast, lo siento. Lo olvidé. Bien, donde esté la cámara...
Bien, buen punto. Gracias, Chris.
La idea era que no sería sólo una laptop
sino que pudiera transformarse en un libro electrónico.
Es una especie de libro electrónico.
Así se ve al aire libre, en blanco y negro.
Faltan los botones de juegos, será para juegos y libros.
Puesto así es un televisor.
Etc., etc. ¿Suficiente? Bien, lo siento.
Dejaré que Jim decida cómo enviarlas después.
Siete países. (Risas)
Quizás para Massachusetts, porque tienen que ofertar.
Por ley hay que ofertar y todo eso.
Por eso casi no puedo nombrarlos.
En otros casos no es necesario. Pueden decidir.
Es el gobierno federal en cada caso.
Es un poco angustiante; muchos dicen:
"Bien, hagámoslo a nivel estatal".
Por supuesto, los estados son más ágiles dado su tamaño.
Y todavía esperamos.
Tratamos con el gobierno federal;
en realidad con los ministerios de educación.
Y si miramos los gobiernos del mundo
los ministerios de educación tienden a ser más conservadores
y a tener nóminas enormes.
Todos piensan que saben de educación,
pero hay mucho de cultura también.
Es difícil. Por cierto, es el camino más difícil.
Los países están distribuidos geoculturalmente.
¿Hay acuerdo unánime? No, no totalmente;
quizá Tailandia, Brasil y Nigeria son los tres más activos
donde casi hay consenso.
Adrede, no hemos firmando nada con nadie
hasta tener los casos testigo.
Y ya que visito cada país al menos cada tres meses,
doy la vuelta al mundo cada tres semanas.
Este es un cronograma,
y abajo anoté que podríamos regalarlas aquí, en dos años.
Todos dicen que no podremos hacer una laptop de 100 dólares.
Y adivinen qué: no podemos.
Probablemente alcancemos los $135. Luego bajará.
Eso es muy importante
porque muchas cosas entran a un precio y luego suben.
Primero a pérdida y luego, cuando se pone interesante,
o no puede costearse o no se puede escalar.
Estamos proyectando 50 dólares para 2010.
El mercado alternativo es importante. Una de las formas, sólo una,
una de las formas de ayudar en los mercados alternativos
es hacer algo totalmente único.
Es como con los autos...
miles de automóviles son robados cada día en EE.UU.
pero nadie roba un camión del correo. Bien, ¿por qué?
Porque no hay un mercado para los camiones del correo.
Parece un camión de correo.
Puedes pintarlo, o hacer cualquier cosa.
Hace poco supe que no robaban Volvos blancos en Sudáfrica.
Punto. Ninguno. Cero.
Queremos hacerlas como un Volvo blanco.
Cada gobierno tiene un grupo de trabajo. Esto puede ser menos interesante,
pero tratamos de lograr que los gobiernos trabajen juntos, y no es fácil.
El plan comercial consiste en comenzar con los gobiernos federales,
y más tarde pasar a otros...
sea un financiamiento niño a niño
así un niño compra una para un niño de otro país en desarrollo,
quizás del mismo género y edad.
Un tío le regala una a un sobrino para su cumpleaños.
Como digo, sucederán todo tipo de cosas,
todas muy, muy interesantes.
Y todos dicen, yo lo digo, es un proyecto educativo.
¿Proveemos el software?
La respuesta es que, obviamente, el sistema tiene software,
pero no, no proveemos el contenido educativo.
Eso se elabora en los países.
Somos construccionistas.
Creemos que se aprende haciendo
y todo, desde Logo, que comenzó en 1968
hasta el más moderno Scratch (no sé si lo conocen)
vienen incluidos.
Ese es el lanzamiento.
¿Estamos soñando? ¿Es real? Sí, lo es.
La única crítica- la gente en verdad no quiere criticar,
porque es un esfuerzo humanitario, sin fines de lucro,
y criticarlo sería algo tonto.
Pero algo criticable era:
es una buena idea pero no podrán hacerlo.
Eso podría significar que estos tipos, profesores, etc., no podrán hacerlo
o que no es posible.
Bien, el 12 de diciembre una empresa llamada Quanta acordó contruirla
y dado que hoy hacen un tercio de las laptops del planeta
esa pregunta desapareció.
Así que no dudamos si sucederá o no. Va a suceder.
Y si cuesta 138 dólares, ¿qué?
Y si sale seis meses más tarde, ¿qué?
Es un aterrizaje bastante suave. Gracias.
(Aplausos)